I am so glad to have this guest on this
is an exclusive it's the first interview
that he's done not get Jared I will
bring on if you could tweet this out my
Twitter too stopped work so does handle
that while we're doing it
I'm and he scandal top trend all over
social media he works with the Fisher
House where they build homes for wounded
veterans and that's he wanted us to plug
it because it's such a nice guy he could
have made it about himself Curt
Schilling thank you for being here sir
well I'm glad you sounds so so chipper
has this been a tough week or you just
kind of I think it's tougher probably on
my family I'm not I don't it's a job not
a not a member of my family and you know
I've got a plan and why I wish I could
say I'm surprised you know that oh no
we're past that at this point um how
long have you worked with with ESPN
forgiving him I'm not a sport honestly
I've worked on and off them for I would
assume close to seven eight nine years
um some of the greatest human beings
I've ever known I get to work with the
people I worked with or some amazing and
good and quality people that's that's
what I miss I miss that part now okay
for people who don't know explain it to
them real quick we'll do two segments
with you here to kind of but explain it
so you were you were relieved of your
duties at ESPN not a one-time thing
I initially this all started out when I
tweeted a meme about Muslim extremists
and I compared them to the Nazi Party
and basically sitting you know it's just
this quote-unquote seven to ten percent
of extremists you know and then
comparing it to the percentage of Nazis
in the in Germany right the Nazi Party
and talking and basically saying oh how
does that work out and then I said
something to the point when you do the
math it's pretty staggering well I was
on a flight to Little League World
Series and I was immediately told to get
on a plane and go home and they put out
a statement almost meet disavowing
themselves of the tweet and my first
response was okay I
no what is your disavowing well but and
and then I quickly realized that
everybody that went batshit crazy it's
so because they took the word extremists
out of the post right which if you do
that it's an incredibly racist thing
which is why I didn't it was the only
word that mattered
you might sweet actually well yeah and
that's they don't care about that so
those defense that was basically to me
the first thing that that told me was my
employer is not only like throwing under
the bus but they're calling me a racist
right well it's also it's also not even
if you remove extremists it's not racist
you have a problem with an ideology and
a religion Islam is not a problem with
Muslims oh my god work with something
sure don't nobody has a problem with
people that are that are you know
everything Muslims you know I probably
extreme I don't care if they were white
extremist black extremist but they're
Muslim extremists and their faith tells
them to kill anyone not of their faith
and this is very much like Nazi Germany
well in Mohammed the point is you know
cuz you can get the territory with was
Muslims I want to get to the more recent
one but Mohammed was a terrorist
Muhammad himself was a terrorist that's
how this one spread around the world
through yes exactly it spread by the
sword
speaking of sword so going forward then
I made a comment about Hillary Clinton
and that comment was basically if she's
guilty sheesh I thought based on the
evidence she's not like she guilty but
she's so guilty she should be under the
jail people took that to mean I wanted
her killed which was wrong and they got
pissed about that too and then they sent
out the memo that everybody gets and it
was the same time what we've done before
but I was a lie I feel like and I have
to look back but I was called out for
the things that I had said while there
were things being said on the other on
many other shows that were very liberal
very progressive racist I mean Steve
makes MIT does it pretty much daily sure
and and so you know I was kind of cured
but then this last one was yes and we
have this up on the screen not gauge
here the mean I responded to a tweet or
to a Facebook post that someone else had
made now there's a couple things to know
about this I responded to it my response
was basically said men's rooms were
clearly
for guys people that stand up to go pee
in women's room not you know I used
words I might not use anyway we all have
turned out to be transphobic right now
the other piece that to know about this
is I made this comment on it and share
this post on and I'm not saying my
private Facebook page but the only
people that can see that the post on my
page in the comment with my friends
quote/unquote friends people friended me
on Facebook so it wasn't public but even
then you know even if it you didn't
because you understand and you are being
tactful because you work with ESPN but
even then suggesting that if you have a
penis that you should use the men's room
should not be something seen as so
hateful and bigoted that here's your job
my point was what the hell was it urinal
mate for I wasn't really busy so I said
it but it's like listen men's rooms were
made for people to go is about them
standing up in women's rooms were not if
they weren't then there would just be
one bathroom everybody would use right
now I became transphobic well that's the
new term right because they have they
have a same-sex marriage they have
same-sex marriage and that was pushed
through Supreme Court and it's over now
and they've accelerated right we're like
okay well now now everyone's transphobic
that's and they just tack it on to the
gay thing to like you see with North
Carolina and there's nothing to do with
today here's the problem first of all
nothing I said was transphobic number
one I when I ran the video company that
went so poorly at the end I had multiple
transgender employees who were some of
the best I have people that I worked
with my son Mike one of my youngest sons
is a member of the LGBTQ Club in high
school he helped the right helps run it
let me ask you to me real quick reform
of transgender employees how do they
fill out that application and and today
did they but I just want to know if they
thought they were pulling the wool over
over car sighs here's the thing I've
come to realize the reason people get
pissed it's because we don't make it as
big a deal as they want it to be right I
don't care I don't care what you wear I
don't care who you sleep with as long as
it's not my wife
don't care what color what race I don't
care about that stuff I've never cared
about that stuff and I'm old enough that
if I had those ghosts in my closet big
deal right
plush last I checked and for the most
part people I know if you're racist
you're not afraid to admit it no yeah
it's nearly not something that's but
that you know that that's what they try
not to so there's a Sikh remember one
used to say well if you used the word
socialist it's code for the n-word for
Barack Obama and now you have Bernie
Sanders who just says I'm a socialist no
we don't believe the n-word book is like
14,000 pages yes well we always think
the code word for something racist well
these are liberal yeah we have our
little we have liquor is a little Orphan
Annie secret decoder pen rigor ok
socialist that lines up with you and
I'll get you one in the mail and we'll
have you back to talk about this Curt
Schilling a nice guy man got the short
of the stick deserves better
a lot of his crowd will be back with him
stay tuned what's theirs so you were
telling a lot a lot of things the the
the under the prison Hillary Clinton was
at a breaking bad reference someone
mentioned that on Twitter yeah okay
great program a little-known fact
overwhelming rated one of the greatest
ever it is really good I liked Sons of
Anarchy first when it came out and then
it got to the point I was like I don't
know how much I can stay with this and
then yeah my wife was in the sons and
then West Wing is still my favorite ever
yeah and then Sons is pretty good but
they keep Breaking Bad was oh my god
yeah it's as good as it gets
yeah and my friend used to actually
write back and forth physically with
Bryan Cranston and a little inside he
was actually thinking about becoming a
priest at one point just really had no
idea he was that talented really well
the baseball commercial that he did was
I don't know if you saw that he's doing
they did the one man baseball show like
a commercial on MLB network or something
it was one of the funniest things I've
ever seen in my life
well I I knew you know not go in the
middle I thought it was it was an
incredibly underrated program and
largely because of him if he wasn't seen
everyone elevated their game and comedo
he was just people don't realize how
what an influential show malcolm in the
middle' was moving toward that
single-camera sitcom in the United
States and I'm always blown away by
good answer has to be to make you hate
their character this like true you know
you start out thinking what he's doing
is like come on how can you be mad at
him he's trying to and then by the end
it's like what a piece of track right it
ended perfect
speaking of hate there are a couple guys
I want to dive much more horrible tests
this isn't right this is true but not
Hillary Clinton we want to clarify
speaking of hate so what's been what was
it what was the process like where you
know you no longer work at ESPN how did
they let you know you said you've met
good did it create some some factions
did you feel thrown under the bus and
then what was the public
I felt kind of from a top level
perspective thrown in bus for quite a
while they think that makes me sound
like a victim and I'm not was that they
maybe drive two hours yesterday to meet
with somebody in HR that he could just
told me like you know I've done many of
those meetings yes you'll probably get a
caller I'm like seriously what I mean
what's the holdup I mean there have you
basically cornered yourself and said not
having an option well the whole thing is
I want to say this about your meme your
meme wasn't even anti-trans for people
who didn't we brought it up earlier they
can go search on Twitter what it was it
was saying if you have a different
opinion you are accused of being a
hateful transphobic bigot it was a
commentary on the social justice warrior
left so my question is is it basically
just 100 and ESPN policy where you have
to have that opinion on the LGBTQ AIP
silent F otherwise you're not welcome
there it's not a secret I mean again if
you listen to the commentary right and I
hate to say it like this because I'm not
loving everybody together cuz again I
had some amazing people I work with but
but here's here's what I might be in
hell do I use with a couple of the
employees there that way I was smoking
with I said listen if I come out
yesterday and said
transgender people are the greatest
people in the world and if you don't
agree you're a son of a [ __ ] they would
have said listen please don't use that
language on the air now it a minute
right other people screaming about you
know First Amendment this and first the
First Amendment doesn't apply here this
is not about freedom of speech
you work for other people you have
consequences if you say things that they
don't get much get along with my problem
is I don't believe you can have a double
standard I don't think it's legal to to
allow one racist opinion and not allow
another if you don't agree with it
right well and also in your defense
commenting there's nothing that you said
was racist I was talking to some people
and I spoke to somebody that was there's
actually transgender and I said listen
we were talking about how this all came
to be and I said you know to be very
clear if you want more people to be
either sympathetic or open to hearing
about your cause then you've got at
least attempt to be tolerant the
tolerant people you want everyone else
to be no animal since I regardless of
anecdotally if you have trans friends
we've had a lot on the show there were
plenty of stops on this logic bus that
said we could have pulled the lever they
didn't want gender-neutral bathroom
that's a perfect solution but they
believe that's the movement the gay stop
oh the trans stop Oh believe it's
discriminatory to have a third bathroom
or it's like okay this is all bets are
off that way everyone's comfortable that
one hasn't has nothing to do the
plumbing finances no no exactly one of
the questions I've got asked though is
when did people believe that the world
was supposed to conform around them
instead of conforming to the world you
live in
or working shaping yourself to the world
you live in people now expect the world
to shape itself for you and I don't
that's not that's not how it works
well that's how they're trying to make
it work right yeah I mean let's not you
know gay people 2 percent of population
errs obviously a play there's nothing
wrong love gay people have them on the
program disagree with some we just had
Dave Rubin on this show super gay
lovely gentleman then you're getting to
trans people you're a single percentage
point of a single percent point and many
of those people aren't at the front
lines fighting for the social justice
bathroom issue you are talking such a
small percentage of people who have so
much control and can get people like you
fired simply for disagreeing that here's
your thing this is one thing this is how
we've gotten to where we are we've
allowed the vocal minority to shut up
everyone else right and now it drives
every all of our political agendas
here's the thing I don't care
transgender marched down my street to
have transgender bathrooms I wouldn't go
out and watch it and I wouldn't care
that they were having it no III want
homeless veterans at home I want orphan
and abused kids to have homes
I want almost problem this country saw
there are so many other things that are
actually legitimately scary right and
dangerous like I don't know Isis but
bile a little-known fact Isis not huge
supporters of the LGBTQ Bruce
Springsteen you know Wow you know you're
awesome
boycott North Carolina so I'm assuming
all your stops in Italy are now canceled
because the same-sex marriage is illegal
in Italy right or Bryan Adams does an
Egypt performing know or executed or
thrown off a roof from the 30 stories if
you're if you're gay if you're a woman
who loses your your scarf or if you're
not a member of the fate well I've made
you know what that might be more
convenient for trans men because all I
need to do in those countries is toss on
the headdress and none but no one's the
problem is that that the world people
pick and choose strategically right
exactly and like the problem is listen
it's not only a minorities obviously
that's a representative the public
Republican not a democracy but like the
Donald Trump came out today we were
really disappointed he said ah they
should leave the laws the way they are
well we're at a point you can't because
Charlotte decided to step in and so the
state had to say no no no no you can't
do this use the bathroom you were born
with you can't come in there was this
was the media to a tee today I saw I was
tested in a post that somebody posted
from a transgender website that said
something to the effect of Curt
Schilling post horrible transphobic meme
calls transgender people pathetic and I
never did that the bottom of the
response I said that we need our
government to step in and make these
laws now is pathetic right yeah well I
do think that if you if you need to be
cradled in a safe space because you
can't use the ladies room when you have
a pecker I would say that person is
pathetic and I don't they don't trans
people are that used to think like
I don't have everybody's talking oh my
god you know people are gonna get ranked
in women's bathrooms it's an issue about
this no it's not what's gonna happen and
you can sure it's already happened but
it's gonna happen one time in a big way
somebody it's gonna get molested in a
woman's room and it's going to be a
child and some scumbag pervert child
molesters going to go to jail and the
transgender community is going to be in
a place they'd never ever want it to be
you guys they're gonna have to be
defending their right to use a bathroom
which opens up the door for you know
what it's just like the whole like anti
police thing right right there most
violent we are ever in history for
Baltimore when they start a bill
fighting men they're amazing women who
put their lives line there are bad eggs
in there and they should be suffer the
worst penalty ever right but that's not
representative of the force like
pedophiles are representative of
transgenders and transgenders are
pedophiles but there are people that
want to annihilate this law to their
advantage and someone is going to get
hurt right yeah I think you're
absolutely right I don't even think
that's necessary well what if they what
if it doesn't happen it doesn't even
matter because again most women are
immensely uncomfortable with it as they
should legal what about men yeah you and
I and and knock each it probably not
uncomfortable in a men's room why
because women aren't naturally sexually
predatory the way men are it's the way
we're wired every single boys fantasy is
to tell us why do I have to know you're
not a real born man well the issues a
lot of women did care and felt
uncomfortable and so cities and
absolutely here's the other piece all
right think about the world two years
ago that we lived in right
and if sooner had happened and no one
had ever known today we will be
different
yes skin would have given the current
award to somebody that was what was a
sentiment day like we did the whole we
did the whole fake Olympics with Caitlyn
Jenner winning the commentary Caitlyn
Jenner if we believe this is a new
person is separate from Bruce
Caitlyn Jenner has precisely as many
athletic accomplishments is not gay
Jared zero and an awardee behind the
scenes at ESPN were even even the the
far left was like yeah okay this is kind
of you know it speak up well in anyway
but but a positive so we no one spoke
about it and you know I don't know cares
honestly who cares and why would you
care if you care that's fine you can go
have your discussion and and the other
piece I try to make these people
understand that I was speaking with an
opinion and a belief or two very
different things right this is an
opinion if my opinion is malleable it's
all of my opinions are most people's art
my belief that Jesus was the son of God
and that my fale and my family is those
things those are unshakable right right
oh boy you're giving far less leeway the
second you make right know if I'm a
racist that's it that's a fundamental
belief of mine that one race is superior
to another right if I'm if I'm
homophobic might my belief my
foundational belief is that game and
aren't worthy of the same life I'm worth
it none of those things are true no but
people but here to think about this what
and this was to me the thing that really
got to me when people are calling you
things that you could not even come
close to being you know somewhere the
wiring screwed up no it comes from top
down it at that point it is going you
know you're right if I was if I said the
n-word in my life my dad would come out
of the grave and pull my heart through
my chest and kill me right I don't I've
never in my life judge somebody on
anything other than how they treated me
and I've had preconceived notions of
people like like I said a douche when I
had to play with a guy and he's like the
greatest thing I've ever had I mean I
learned that enough times to know right
but what people are calling you a racist
and you well what's been the public
reaction is my question cuz we can get
into the back room so I appreciate you
having a the Muslim thing came out it
was the same thing like they reacted in
two days later they everybody I'm going
in circles but this is like 9/11 right
9/11 everybody was cut this country's
the grace well let's go kick everybody's
ass
right and then the really loud folks
they die out in about six months right
it's no different all these people
screaming and yelling in 48 hours are
going to be moving on to something else
because I got fired and they're all
happy well I think this though I think
you have I think I think you got more
support than the SPN expected yeah I
don't think I think they're pushing way
too hard right now too fast and this may
have a rebound effect cuz if you look if
you look at social media it wasn't even
split a majority of people thought that
this was pretty ridiculous and I think
it's people who did didn't agree with
the thing I posted we're saying the same
like right it says ridiculous we have to
go mr. Schilling thank you so much and I
know you're gonna start going on this
tour and everyone's gonna want a piece
of you if there's ever anything we can
do let us know but thank you for
stopping by and man I appreciate that
you're willing to stand on tomorrow
morning so that should be a lot of fun
Curt Schilling thank you sir we must go
louder with Cotter stay tuned as we wrap
it up hey glad to see you subscribe by
clicking my face or the button above
that says subscribe I know you don't
have to you can close the window but
joke's on you there's a pipe bomb in
your basement and I have the detonator I
highly recommend you subscribe and even
then you're still rolling the dice it
depends on my mood is that day